so let's have a little look at message
authentication codes which are slightly
more interesting than they sound so
people shouldn't which off yet on the
internet when we send messages we often
send them encrypted the idea being that
we don't want people to read them that
makes a lot of sense
the issue is that not being able to read
the message doesn't mean you can't
interfere with the message you can't
start changing the message trying to
I've erect the communication or alter
surreptitiously the communication to say
something that you want this is where
message authentication codes become a
really big deal max as we call them are
attached to most of the messages that
get sent on the internet however they're
built into the cypher or they are
appended to every message that gets sent
even if it's encrypted and they
basically guarantee that the message
haven't been changed so let's have a
little bit of a look at that but first
let's have a quick look at an example of
what you can do if you start officially
changing ciphertext usually when we're
encrypting data online we are view the
block cipher or use a stream cipher like
they each have pros and cons and a
detailed look at each of those is for a
different time but a stream cipher
they're quite common you know when you
do things like streaming video because
they let you often seek straight to the
middle of somewhere and it also very
very quick right so mobile
communications you stream cyphers quite
a lot
instead of encrypting a message of a key
it will actually just use the key to
generate a long pseudo-random key stream
for as long as it's required and then we
use XOR to actually perform the
encryption so basically we start
flipping bits of a plaintext to get to
the ciphertext
now the difficulty with this is that we
can bend as a sort of malicious third
party just flip the bits back all right
so we can flip the bits in the
ciphertext and they will cause a direct
change in the input all right so I'm
going to show a quick example just to
show you the kind of problem we're
dealing with so I've got here a an XOR
calculated I found so I'm going to put
in a message please send my 100 pounds
this is just a calculator who doesn't
actually perform keystream generations
I've got a key stream that I've I'm
going to paste it in here so this is my
key stream which is just in hex well
that's your stream come from is not just
oh I will actually generated it by just
putting random nonsense into another
stream cipher you could generate this
any way you like it has to appear random
if it's not random
enuine rules have all the straight
incisor for the sake of this small
example which is just random enough so
you know so if I calculate the XOR on
this we get a message in let's say
hexadecimal which is completely nonsense
right this is our encrypted message if
you view this as ASCII it won't say this
and it won't say anything useful at all
the problem is if I start changing the
bits here and we reverse this process
for decryption we can actually change
the amount I get sent like which
unfortunately this is a purely
hypothetical example I don't actually
get any money so in a block cipher
because the whole block is encrypted as
one usually any kind of bit change in
this ciphertext will completely wreck
the output when you try and decrypt it
that is not true of a stream cipher a
stream cipher is one bit at a time which
means that if I change a bit in my
ciphertext I can flip bits in my
plaintext so let's try this if I put my
encoded in hex in my input the key stays
the same and we can't play it the XOR
you can see that we've decrypted two
please send micro hundred pounds but if
I flip so these each of these bytes here
corresponds to a bite of this ASCII if I
change this to a 31 and then I can't
play the XOR on it I'm suddenly being
sent 900 pounds that's a huge profit if
we weren't doing something else which of
course is what I'm about to get to
extreme size will be completely useless
practically because you could just
change the message even if you didn't
know what it is things like bank
transactions and logins and things like
this are always sent in the same format
it doesn't make sense for a bank to
change the format they use all the time
so although they're going to be more
complicated than please send Mike person
please send Mike which is computer
although very more complicated than this
they're not a lot more complicated and
so the same bit will often correspond to
the same part of the transaction account
numbers the values this kind of thing so
we can't allow people halfway middlemen
to start flipping bits because it's
gonna cause a real problem
so people have luckily spotted this
problem and dealt with it already right
so I'm going to explain how it's done
well you can imagine we might do is a
bit like a checksum right so we've got a
message here right that we want to try
and verify that haven't been tampered
with so I'm sending you a message this
is my message so
what I do is I hash this message or I
can't paid chips I'm on it or something
like that and I append that hash to the
end of the message so think back to our
video on char one the hash is just a
usually shorter fixed length string that
is essentially a summary or fingerprint
of this message and the idea usually is
that we can't find another hash for a
different message but it's the same so
the problem here can you finish what it
is surely you can just still change yeah
it's totally useless like I've don't do
this if you're watching this please
don't quit the video now and go
brilliant we've got the solution and the
problem is if I'm a third party I
intercept this message I stop the
transmission I then changed this message
to be whatever I want and then I
recompute the hash and attach it and
then the person verifying this message
on the other end hashes it goes all the
hashes match this is the kind of naive
approach which is isn't going to work
long term all right this works on like
your disk for making sure that a file
hasn't got like checksum errors and
things like this beyond that if a
security not going to work what we need
to have is some kind of shared secret
like wall of these things so let's
imagine that you and I have shared a key
okay right so we have this secret key
that only you and I know what we can do
is we can take our message and we can
instead produce a hash of K appended to
the message like this right again don't
quit the video yet we're not I'm going
to hit ourselves this is better right
it's not complete solution but it's
better the nice thing about this is that
because I knew you and I know the key
right which is it kind of the assumption
of encryption then no one else can
change the message they alter the
message they aren't going to be able to
recompute this hash because they don't
have the key that's the idea so this is
called a message authentication code now
that works okay the problem is the hash
functions we use like sha-1 and sha-256
are based around this merkle-damgard
construction which essentially changes
their internal state and the problem is
you can kind of resume that state and
basically append to the message we can
maybe talk about laser extension attacks
another time exactly how they work but
the idea is that I could append to this
message and be able to calculate a new
hash reasonably well right and it's not
that difficult to do as long as I can
guess the length of the
ed key right which is not that hard
compared to getting the actual key so
this isn't going to work for current
hash function ja three isn't susceptible
for this but Shafi doesn't see as much
as sha-256 at moment so this brings us
on to our kind of true say our actual
usable technique called the H Mac which
is the H ma see the keyed hash message
authentication code it's actually pretty
similar to a standard message of
indication code except with two hashes
involved and it's completely immune to
length extension attacks so what we do
is we take our key and we use it to
derive two sub Keith's like K 1 and K 2
so this is K 2 this is K 1 and then we
calculate our hash of K 1 with our
message and then we append that to K 2
and we hash it again okay so Q nice
animation but the idea is you can't
perform the same length extension attack
on this message because essentially we
would have to know what the internal
state of our hash function was after
this middle point which we wouldn't know
like we were as we do know it here I
mean I think only personally I will be
happy to derive is that IA there's no
massive got a very good question
okay so be it either derived by
basically taking two constants and XOR
in them with the key separately okay so
we have one constant then we just
compare what they are on person idling
yeah what's the I pad RB inner pad is 36
and the outer pad is 5c okay this inner
pad here is the iPad which is oh what
concerns the other half of the I'll pass
along on a minute I think the age mat
construction was first constructed in
1996 so we this one did like actually
this doesn't stand for I in terms of
information or you know internet or
anything webby this is it's this hyper
internal so the iPad is our X 36 in hex
the outer pad 53 those were chosen sort
of arbitrarily it's not very important
what they are actually these are kind of
like nothing up my sleeve numbers but
they have it they have a
for people who watch david Wells's video
they have a large Hamming distance
between the two but the point is that
they have they have that many bits in
common and they're not exactly the same
which is crucial look more and more
random as we go and at the same time
we're bringing in bits from this message
to further increase the appearance of
randomness but also to make sure that
this char function is calculating a
digest on this specific message rather
than just a general one that's the same
every time for this